- [Instructor] Where we
left off in the last video,
the first Saudi state,
the Emirate of Diriyah,
was ended in the Ottoman-Wahhabi War.
It was ended by the Ottomans,
but it was by actual Egyptian forces
that retook control of Mecca and Medina
and then laid siege to
the town of Diriyah,
which was the center of
the Emirate of Diriyah.
The last emir, who was
also considered imam,
so a religious leader,
of the Emirate of Diriyah was Abdullah,
who was beheaded by the Ottoman Turks.
Now, that wasn't the end
of the House of Saud.
As we have alluded to,
there's going to be two more Saudi states.
A cousin of Abdullah's
father, Turki bin Abdullah,
who had gone into hiding after
the Egyptian forces had
taken control of Diriyah,
was able to come back
to power in the 1820s,
and he establishes the second Saudi state,
the Emirate of Nejd.
And as we talked about
in the previous video,
the Nejd refers to that
central Arabian region,
which was really the stronghold
of the House of Saud.
And we can see here
that the Emirate of Nejd
eventually expands to much
of the Arabian Peninsula,
although it never took
control of Mecca and Medina,
which were back under Ottoman control.
Now, this emirate will
last until the last decade
of the 19th century, as
we get into 1890 and 1891,
when a rival tribe, the Rashidun,
are able to take Riyadh.
At that time, Turki bin
Abdullah's grandson,
Abdul Rahman bin Faisal,
is now emir and imam,
so both the head of state
and as imam religious leader.
When the Rashidun take over,
he and his family go into exile
with Bedouin tribes in the south
and eventually make their way to Kuwait.
Abdul Rahman himself eventually
focuses more on religion,
but his son, Abdul Aziz,
will end up becoming
one of the most significant
figures in all of Saudi history.
In 1902,
he is able to take back Riyadh.
He and roughly 40 men are able
to scale the protective walls
of Riyadh by climbing
bent-over palm trees.
They're able to take the town.
And then from there,
they establish what ends up
becoming the third Saudi state.
He soon takes back the Nejd region
and then, in World War I,
takes the side of Great Britain
against the Ottoman Empire.
After World War I, he's
able to take the Hejaz,
this western region of
the Arabian Peninsula,
including Mecca and Medina.
And in 1932, it's officially
proclaimed a kingdom,
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia,
which included both
the Hejaz and the Nejd.
And all of this was
done by King Abdulaziz.
And as you can see here,
his reign covered half
of the 20th century.
And over the next 70 years,
every king of Saudi Arabia
has been one of his sons,
and the current Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia,
Mohammed bin Salman, is his grandson.
And King Abdulaziz and Saudi Arabia
become major actors on the
global stage when, in 1938,
major oil reserves are discovered
in Saudi Arabia near the Persian Gulf.
And these end up being some of the largest
oil reserves in the world.
So this became a strong
incentive for major world powers
to become allied with Saudi Arabia,
especially the United States.
This right over here is a picture of FDR,
the American president,
meeting King Abdulaziz in 1945,
near the end of World War II.
And you could appreciate
the strategic importance
of these oil reserves.
They're important for growing economies,
and they are also important
from a military point of view.
World War I and even more so World War II
are defined by mechanized militaries
that need oil in order to operate.
And just to get an
appreciation of Saudi Arabia's
continued strategic importance
from an energy point of view,
this right over here shows
the production of petroleum
and natural gas for the
United States, Russia,
and Saudi Arabia over
the last several years.
And these tend to be
the top three producers
of petroleum and natural gas.
But if you focus on petroleum,
you see that, for most
of this time period,
Saudi Arabia was the top producer,
and it's actually true of
most of the post-war era.
Recently, the United States
has passed up Saudi Arabia,
but even then Saudi Arabia is incredibly
strategically important
because it uses far less
of its petroleum than
the United States does.
So Saudi Arabia is still the world's
largest exporter of petroleum,
and the reserves that
Saudi Arabia has access to
are far cheaper to access than, say,
the reserves in the United States.
So they continue to be very strategic
and very important actors
on the global stage.